selon gira tour est il trop cher faut-il
encadrer les loyers comme à paris et
lille c'est en tout cas la demande de
l'association de consommateurs
tourangelle la clcv
en ligne de mire des factures locatifs
qui augmente chaque année
ainsi que des charges excessives alors
que certaines habitations ne respectent
pas tous les critères de sécurité ou de
confort thermique romain delville avec
florent clavel en termes de loyers tour
n'est pas paris ni lille ni même
bordeaux ou lyon des villes qui ont déjà
des loyers encadrés ou qui s'apprêtent à
en avoir
il augmente mais par rapport aux
prestations qui proposent par la suite
bon c'est pas toujours ça suffit pas
toujours
donc c'est ça un peu le problème
franchement je me plains pas je suis
bien entouré je trouve que franchement
on a de la chance dans cette ville le
voeu de de ne pas pouvoir payer trop
cher pour avoir un appartement qui est
bien pour l'association de consommateurs
clcv il faudrait généraliser un
encadrement des loyers dans les grandes
villes y compris à tour l'association
constate des augmentations de loyer
anormal lorsque les locataires change et
environ 80 % des propriétaires bailleurs
d'une façon générale et agences
immobilières qui respecte
malheureusement il y en a quand même 20%
qui respectent pas qu'ils respectent pas
des loyers disons d'un prix correct
l'encadrement des loyers une très
mauvaise idée selon l'union nationale
des propriétaires immobilier pour qui ce
type de mesure est avant tout un
marqueur politique pour les villes
concernées à titre principal cela ne
profite qu'aux locataires les plus juger
et des locataires les plus modestes n'en
bénéficient pas ensuite ça diminue
l'offre locative et en troisième lieu
sur un site les propriétaires au lieu de
louer des logements nu à faire du meublé
la ville de tours avait jusqu'en
novembre pour demander l'encadrement des
loyers
elle ne l'a pas fait la clcv défendra
son implication auprès des élus de la
ville à la mi février